so when I had a conversation with Elam
musk he
suggested that what Israel should do his
conspicuous acts of
kindness so do as much
positive things in Gaza as possible on a
basic individual human level and at a
policy level at every level what do you
think about that I mean you don't pass
out candy in a concentration camp you
end the occupation and so there has to
be a solution that is beyond merely acts
of kindness at the end of the day if
you're occupying a
people you have to remove that
occupation apartheid is not dealt with
by acts of kindness on the part of the
occupying power a paride is dealt with
by ending a paride and so there has to
be a level of accountability it's not
just acts of kindness It's not just uh
treating the people with more dignity
it's giving them the ability to pursue
their own dignity there's a reason why
it's called Palestinian
self-determination the United States
likes to use it in all of its
inconsequential statements that we need
Palestinian self-determination too but
the United States also voted against 138
States and the United Nations to allow
for Palestinian
self-determination uh self-determination
means I get to pursue my own course of
worth I get to pursue my own happiness I
don't have to depend on the benevolence
of my occupier and when my occupier
feels like you know throwing me a few
more crumbs it has to end there has to
be a point now where the world says this
is not sustainable it's not just about
ending the present genocide a ceasefire
is the bare minimum I think any decent
human being would be calling for a
ceasefire right now but at some point
you cease occupation you cease apartheid
because what led to the ability of
Israel to carry out a genocide without
any accountability
was that the global Arena has permitted
it to do so largely due to American
obstruction of
justice